Stephanie is with us in Fort Wayne
Indiana
hi Stephanie how are you okay I'm doing
pretty good yourself
better than I deserve what's up well I
was calling because I am I'm a beginner
with Dave Ramsey SPT like this received
all my information yesterday to get set
up online good so I mean I'm in the
process of picking all of my debt and
you know putting it together to see
where I just start you know smallest to
largest of course and I actually looked
at my civil judgments that I have
against me for like spa claims court and
I have a variety of past medical bills
that dates back all the way to 2001 and
I actually had somebody told me that off
that fat off that old like they can't
still come after me for that day and I
was just calling to see I'm pretty sure
I know what you're going to say if it's
on the same track as me you know it's
assets that I owe but I was calling to
see if that is true yeah well there is
some states have a statute of
limitations on old bad debt okay okay
and if they have not done some things
like sue you and get a judgment and keep
the judgment updated and some things
like that then their ability to collect
an old debt that's just sitting there in
collections does I say it goes away but
legally they'd have trouble suing you in
some states there's a statute of
limitations on those and so that part
might be true what is true and so
there's three or four lenses to look at
this through there's theory which that's
the theory lens
okay theoretically they couldn't collect
it and so and you don't know it anymore
under the law so theoretically it's gone
okay but that's just theory in the real
world
you're gonna get a call about two months
for you get ready to buy a house and
they're gonna Jack you around and mess
up something about the time you get
ready to buy the house and this is going
to come back to haunt you
that's the practical that's the
practical lens to look at it through the
the moral lens to look at it through is
yeah I owe the money I need to pay my
bill if I can if there's any way you can
pay your bill you pay your bill right
and so there's two or three you know the
spiritual lens it's the same one I need
to repay when I can if there's any way I
can so I tend to tell you to go clean it
up it's not anything I'm panicked about
and so what I would tell you to do is do
two different debts snowballs okay let's
do a debt snowball with the debts that
you have that are active today do you
have debts like a car payment or
somebody you're paying payments up to
today that you're current with and
active with which I call the beast
that's the biggest one and then I have
credit cards that which I'm currently
paying off and then recent medical bills
of course recent okay and then you've
got how much old debt that is in
judgment or that's just been sitting out
there forever that you're not paying
[Music]
somewhere in there okay all right so
here's what I would do I would clear up
all of your current debt first let's let
this those dogs are asleep let sleeping
dogs lie for right now on that old stuff
and so let's list our current debts
smallest to largest clear those up
because every time you clear up one of
those it frees up more money clearing up
an old one that you're not paying on
doesn't free up any money in your budget
you see what I'm doing okay so once we
once we clean up and you don't have any
payments but a house payment now you got
some wiggle room you got some stuff you
can be doing now and then we make a list
of those old ones smallest to largest of
what we think they are you contact them
and you may find an old one that was two
hundred and fifty dollars
from 2001 they may be trying to collect
$5,000 in late fees collections fees
interest they may have gone crazy okay
and yeah and then you just have to begin
to negotiate with them and go no I'm not
smoking dope over here I just called you
to pay you there's a difference okay and
so what I'm going to do is I'm going to
offer you the original amount of $250 as
a settlement in full get that in writing
do not give them electronic access to
your checking account you can go back
and settle those for the original amount
easily and maybe less now I wouldn't I
wouldn't put a lot of effort under the
on the ones that are under $1,000 but if
out of that $8,000 worth or $6,000 worth
if you got a $4,000 when laying there
yeah I'm gonna put a little effort in
trying to settle that one for around a
thousand bucks it's a really old debt
any money they get right now is what's
known as a gift because they're gonna
have trouble collecting it because of
the statute of limitations you can
actually bring that up and just go you
can't collect this I'm just trying to
settle it to get you out of my life and
because it's the right thing to do and
you can just begin to talk that through
with them but first thing you do is
clear up the old ones the new ones the
current ones and then that gives you the
room to attack the old ones this is the
Dave Ramsey show